whenever growing up your friends thought
of thought you were crazy to want to
pursue a sort of a Hollywood career or
career in film and television and yet
you went ahead with it anyway you know
why didn't you listen to your friends
well actually I i started in live
television in nineteen work to their
1952 and a lot of my friends thought
that I said what are you doing so I'm
working in television I said uh it's a
little it'll vote last more than two or
three years it's it's just like a toy he
said you know and then and then I said
well I don't think so i think it's gonna
be they said people are not good people
not want people going to want to go out
at night to they want to put the theater
they want to go to movie houses they
don't stay at home to be entertained I
said well I think you're wrong and and
then as I watched I started as a
stagehand but what happened was of
course that when when i first started to
work to the cdc there's only 200 people
working for it within a year there were
2,000 people working so of course the
original 200 rose up were naturally
lifted up and I got a chance to direct
when I was 24 it's ridiculous I was the
youngest director in Canada at the time
but after a couple of years working in
live television it was a great school
because there were no film schools then
but this live television every three
weeks comedy drama action suspense
whatever it was historical info I am so
I had learned a lot by we're actually
working you know and after about two
years I decided that I wanted to be a
film director and Canada at the time
there was no such thing as the film
industry there's little theatre and no I
know films so I wasn't sure whether I
wanted to be if maybe a stage director
as well so I decided to go to London it
was easy for Canadian didn't need a work
permit to work in London at the same
time in the one city there was
television theatre and film so I was
able to work on all three all through
the 60s
you